vans will feed webside to garland
garland flattens of the whole folder he
stores by garlic yes getting the chance
to get inside the defendant cameo Jala
as we enter to the Celtics are one step
back nice little back fool I like that
dribble to get back into the defender
had no chance or they could do the
standing watch not let's grab the loose
ball and double off the borders order
now to Sexton down the lane lays it up
and in Sexton with back-to-back buckets
he comes to Celtic Lee - 31:23 good job
right there retrieved the ball and then
take off use your speed that's what they
had so use it but you got to get those
rebounds so you can get out and open
troy then rookie guards on truly good
shooters about this on Sunday is that's
it lets go baseline on spring they
played solid in Boston also the garland
to the basket he backs it up and in and
he got around Kaiser gates the rookie
head of Xavier garland now the fire at
jumper and score drifting three wide
areas gone Martin with the rebound
[Music]
sex we got tangled up Pines weighed
under dinky laser dominant
[Applause]
taco time to get back and make sure
rejection well I'm up top and tender for
tavant a green is broken up you got that
big you got to get you clowns across
quick like garlic here's the no-look
pass by garlic yeah good pass inside I
think it seems like a couple of seasons
ago when the NBA crackdown on an Jackson
way to the rim yep good pass inside keep
your head up